welcome back we're rejoined by our guest
congressman trey Gowdy and John
Radcliffe of Texas to discuss the GOP
agenda in 2018 and whether the Trump
agenda can overcome the Democrats
resistance Newt Gingrich has a piece out
today on Fox news.com that says quote
the great political surprise of 2018
will be the size of the Republican
victory end quote on the other hand GOP
congressman Charlie dent of Pennsylvania
is not seeking re-election and he isn't
nearly as optimistic we're in a very
challenging midterm environment you know
the party the president you typically
you know loses about 32 seats in a
midterm like this so I think most of my
colleagues are well aware of the
historical challenges that we face of
course then Donald Trump you know
complicates that because he's a very
polarizing figure and so I suspect that
our challenges will be even greater just
because of that that from Charlie dent a
current member of Congress on the
Republican side of the aisle gentlemen I
start with the trey Gowdy here you know
the Speaker of the House also plays a
very important role as as does the
president Paul Ryan as the Speaker of
the House I'm not aware of any speaker
who's ever gone unscathed he takes on a
very difficult position but congressman
Gowdy you from your perspective you've
got a front and center seat with Paul
Ryan how's he doing what's your
perspective on on the speaker Jason
there are a lot of good members of
Congress in my co guest tonight is one
of my favorites but I'll bet you Johnny
would agree with me when I say there is
no one better qualified to be the
Speaker of the House than Paul Ryan is
every quality that you want in a leader
he is smart he is principled he is
inclusive and most importantly he is
reluctant he did not want to be the
Speaker of the House he wanted to be the
chairperson ways and means but when
Kevin McCarthy dropped out of the
speaker's race we had no one to turn to
so we went and said will you lead us and
he reluctantly did so he is the smartest
kid in the class he would be my number
one draft choice if I were starting this
government all over again I don't know
how long he wants to remain Speaker but
he's done us a favor by taking the job
and I can't think of anybody
that could do the job as well as he's
doing it right now now congressman
Radcliffe a lot of people don't know
this about your background but you're
actually the subcommittee chairman on
cybersecurity you as a performer
prosecutor we're prosecuting terrorism
cases you look at the 90 billion dollars
a year that our federal government
spends on cyber and cyber security
efforts it is a very dangerous thing in
this country what what keeps you up at
night as you look at cybersecurity and
the challenges facing the United States
well Jason I think you and Trey have
both heard me say this before that I
consider a cybersecurity to be the
greatest threat to our national security
listen I think we are at far greater
danger from invasions of our digital
borders right now than any invasion of
our physical borders and people just
need to turn on their computers open up
their papers every day and see another
breach another hack that has increased
in sophistication and severity and the
point is this that the United States
will only remain the world's superpower
if we're also the world's cyber
superpower and so as much as we're
spending in this field right now it's
not enough it's the great equalizer
cyberspace is right now it's the new
frontier and it's how a country like
North Korea that can't compete with the
United States with kinetic firepower can
compete with us in cyberspace so we've
got to really dedicate our efforts this
is an area that I've enjoyed legislating
in but we've got to continue to do that
in a smart way where we can raise the
cyber hygiene and cyber IQ of every
American so that we're safer and that we
do maintain the status as the world's
cyber superpower a lot of issues facing
the United States and one of the things
that you hear particularly if you listen
to the mainstream media and those
outside the Beltway is the contention
the difficult nature of coming up with
bipartisan solutions that you would
think that the body doesn't get along
now now trey gowdy I know you've been
writing a book for some time now was
Senator Tim Scott also of South Carolina
tell me about the book and your
perspective on the you know atmosphere
in Washington DC
well Jason
Scot is the best person in all of
politics the two guys I'm with tonight
are really really good people but I
think Tim Scott's the best person in
politics and as you to know because you
stop by our dinner table he and I are
virtually inseparable we also did not
know each other in 2010 when we came in
as freshmen we have different
backgrounds we have different life
experiences we frankly have different
views on some pretty significant issues
but we have just chosen to have a
friendship some would call unlikely
because we are more interested in the
conciliation than we are the conflict so
what we want to do is share the story of
our relationship and try to encourage
our fellow citizens I do think there is
a hunger for conciliation for unity in
this country contrast is fine I'm glad
we don't all pull for the Cowboys I'm
glad we don't all go watch the same
movie at the same time but but the
contrast has morph into conflict and
what I hear almost everywhere I go is a
sense of angst this divisiveness we are
the United States of America so I would
love for us to spend almost as much time
celebrating what we have in common is we
do harping on the differences and Timmy
and I look how our hair is different we
come from different backgrounds we your
hair is like for it on almost a daily
basis so yeah that's true my hair is
different from my own hair but if you
put up a picture of Tim Scott now you
can see how we have differences but but
but we made a conscious effort to
celebrate the things that we have in
common and Jason I'm telling you you
served there whether it's Joey Kennedy
or Seth Moulton or or Christian cinema
or Tulsi Gabbard or Peter Welch those
are all Democrats on the other side of
the aisle I know this story doesn't get
out and some of some of your viewers and
some of the viewers of other television
shows frankly don't want to hear it but
99.9% of us get along really well in our
personal interactions it's just we have
this hyper focus on conflict in this
country so the fact that we get along
doesn't make the news what does make the
news is if there's one member on either
side yelling at each other that night so
I I'm interested in conciliation in
unity and what binds us together as
fellow Americans
that's what Timmy and I want to write
about well listen it's been an honor and
privilege to serve with you while I did
in the United States Congress parting
quick word John Radcliffe I don't know
if you have any sort of New Year's
resolution or good movie that you saw or
some word of wisdom going into the new
year but well my new year's resolution
one of the things that chairman Gowdy is
always telling me is that I should ask
better questions of witnesses at
congressional hearings and since he's a
lot older and wiser mostly older I'm
gonna take that advice to heart in 2018
trey gowdy do you have any words of
wisdom going into 2018 or any good movie
or show that you saw or that provides
some inspiration well I want to say this
I want to wish you a julie a happy new
year and Johnny I want to wish you and
Michelle a Happy New Year and Jason was
a privilege to serve with you and Johnny
you know that you are my favorite member
of the house in terms of holiday movies
one that I have found inspirational this
season is narcos season three if you
like movies about about families and
family businesses I would recommend
narcos yeah that that's a feel-good pick
me up way to get a long movie
yeah rather long way I thought he was
gonna I thought he was gonna say Bad
Santa but okay will not let me wash Bad
Santa
thank you again very much